foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
create examples
always
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the city is back and it's exciting
it's a fantastic Film Festival that
really gets to the soul and the Heart of
downtown New York filmmaking
[Music]
it's about the Vibrance of the culture
of New York
immersive experience
we share our narratives now differently
there are so many more things that games
can be
ever since I was a kid I would play
video games 24 7. every time I wanted to
relax every time I wanted to step out of
the world for a bit
you know this people might say well go
read a book I'm like I don't want to
read a book I want to be in an
interactive Adventure
I want to feel like I'm part of the
story
I am Julian Cordero and my game is
desperate
goodbye Volcano High
strike odds
a Highland song
[Music]
nightscape
the expanse
welcome welcome welcome welcome to
Tribeca games
[Music]
I must have claimed the hell behind the
house a hundred times
I know every stone
but after that Hill
another
and then another again
and after all that the
sea
and I've never been there a Highland
song is a narrative Adventure game set
in the world of the Scottish Highlands
you play as Moira McKinnon a teenager on
her way to the Sea for the first time
but to get there you're gonna have to
find your way through the wild mountains
and The Valleys you'll have to survive
the weather and you'll learn a bit about
the stories and the history of the
Highlands on the way
incle is an independent game Studio
based in the UK and we specialize in
narrative games so we make games in all
sorts of genres but our main focus is on
games that tell really strong stories
our most famous game is probably 80 Days
an adaptation of Jules Verne's classic
novel the main hook of 80 days is that
you can go around the world any way you
like the way that Highland song works is
extremely similar to 80 Days you start
in one particular point and you can
choose all sorts of different routes
through the highlands in order to reach
your goal
but it also ends at a single point
because you're trying to reach the
lighthouse where your uncle Hamish lives
by the sea
finding the right gameplay for a game
like a Highland song could be really
difficult gameplay is usually built
around loops and patterns but good
narratives aren't made out of Loops we
want to make sure that the character
isn't doing anything just for the sake
of gameplay but everything the character
is doing has to make sense within the
narrative
so the reason that we've essentially
created our very first platforming game
is that it just makes sense for the
character within this scenario to be
jumping and scrambling over rocks
and it even has a rhythm action mechanic
so in many ways it's the most gamey game
that we've ever created
[Music]
moira's platforming abilities in a
Highland song are quite realistic she
has a limited amount of time that she
can climb
she gets hurt she falls too far
she could rest to recover her strength
she gets affected by weather and
affected by night time and affected by
coal a lot of our mechanics are built
around the tension between knowing where
you are and being lost we have a map
mechanic which is all about that it's
about finding little pockets of
Knowledge Learning the names of Peaks
and understanding the history of the
piece to help you find your way through
this world
[Applause]
[Music]
I think who we've always loved
hand-drawn 2D illustration we we love
how expressive it can be especially for
characters even when we made 3D games we
still had 2D characters because we loved
the overall effect
[Music]
I grew up in Scotland when I was a
teenager I went up into the Scottish
Highlands with three friends and we got
lost and we had to stumble Through
Rivers and bogs it was really quite a
chilling scary experience
my parents are art historians and that
there was always one painting in
particular that they had that I used to
love as a child it had a little ruined
castle by Lark and these Scots pine
trees and this golden brown color
palette that was just so characteristic
of the region and so going for a really
painterly aesthetic was a way to capture
that the more modern take on that is the
digital paintings of concept artists
such as Paul Scott Caravan who we worked
with on this project and he came up with
this really beautiful way of hand
painting rocks and trees and grass and
then assembling them as a huge collage
but then all built up so that the
overall effect is of a painting coming
to life
when people play a Highland song I
really want them to come away with a
strong sense of the place the highlands
themselves there's this tension in that
place between being full of story and
history and the marks left behind by
people whether that's ruined farm houses
or whether that's just the names
attached to the various peaks of the
stories behind those names which often
go back a very very long way indeed
first kind of conceived of the game I
tried to forget everything about what
games we'd made as a studio before what
what games are out there and I just
tried to
imagine what do I want on my switch for
me to play right now and pretty much a
Highland song as the way it looks and
feels popped into my head and I can't be
prouder of what we've created
[Music]
Co-op is a game Studio that's based
originally in Montreal but is now remote
and worldwide
it is a Cooperative basically that means
that we make all major decisions
together we decide whether we want to
work four days or five days um spoiler
alert we decided to do four days a long
time ago we present Concepts when we are
starting to put together things and we
all vote on what we think is what
everybody would like to work on and you
feel more attached to what you're making
because you voted for it you chose it it
was really important for us to feel like
this was a different space where people
actually could be the voices behind the
games that we make we are the makers of
some charming fun games like winding
worlds and nog and the upcoming goodbye
Volcano High goodbye volcano high is a
cinematic visual novel about dinosaurs
in their final year of high school at
the start of the year they find out that
a meteor is coming
and the game is about asking yourself
what would you do if you had one year
left who would you be who would you want
to love and how would you want to go out
I vote Yes
I don't think this is a voting type
situation
I mean it does kind of belong to all of
us
or
it was supposed to
it does
you did a great job
so
what do you say Fang
we chose dinosaurs for goodbye volcano
high for a couple of reasons originally
when we presented the game to everybody
else it was meant to be a dating Sim
because like at the time this was kind
of like the hot
to work on
was was dating Sims and then we were
like hold up hold up here's the hook
it's a dating Sim with dinosaurs at the
end of the world as soon as you start
talking about a meteor even though the
characters are unsure what's gonna
happen
you know it's gonna happen and that was
really important to us because we wanted
to make something that could tap into
the anxiety of our current times and
dinosaurs was a really great way to
create that metaphor uh instantly as it
went on and we became kind of more
ambitious and more interested in making
what we actually like we were like what
if it's an anime and we tell a story
that isn't necessarily so focused on
dating but really goes deep into the
emotional aspects of the end of the
world
so a high school already feels like it's
the end of the world to most people so
it wasn't really that hard to hone in on
the teammates it's really the hope
that's tricky to encapsulate high school
to me is all about that sweet sweet
balance of Doom and hope hope for the
better future hope for the dreams you
chase and the Ambitions we strive for
those are things that can feel
impossible to cling to especially with
something that can't be stopped and
feels inevitable like a giant meteor
hitting you and communities all across
the continent reacted to the news of a
previously unknown space object this
morning
so how do you deal with that it starts
off very joking they're kind of making
Gallows humor jokes in light of the
whole Space Rock potential demise of
civilization thing
My Chosen theme feels off
what's the theme using this here too
um make an impact
our characters all have different
methods of coping some double down on
their Ambitions turned to accomplish
their dreams before it's too late others
slow down and decide to savor what time
they have left regardless of what their
dreams are we can still win battle of
the bands asteroid or not the player
character essentially ends up being the
UI and you end up playing as Fang's
inner monologue
[Music]
I think this means she's rooting for us
music is really important in goodbye
Volcano High and I would actually say
music is really important to our studio
and all of our games it's core to our
DNA and music is Central to the identity
of the people who make the game and so
it is Central to the identity of the
game itself and the characters within it
there's no performance in this game that
that is separate
essentially the same as having a a scene
of dialogue but you're playing music
[Music]
the Fang is kind of gearing up for their
future as a musician and then realizing
that they may not have a future anymore
so those two things are kind of clashing
in their brain for the music they're
creating and singing in the game foreign
I think every person hopes that they get
to be near people they love and who
understand them and that love them those
are things people can grasp no matter
how much time they have left I think
that this game really encourages people
to be brave to do the brave thing and
love each other and be there for each
other even when it's scary even when you
don't know what's gonna happen
[Music]
foreign
this is
[Music]
foreign
Adventure game where the ancient Arabian
Night Sky loses its light
[Music]
you play as Layla who is an astronomer
who just loves to look at the night sky
as Layla players wield the magical
astrolabe restoring stars back to
constellations in order to seek a path
home
a key Stellar cast member is the goat
kid constellation the Go kid decides to
accompany Leila in her journey these
days people do not know much about
constellations and the stories behind
them especially Arabic constellations
they're different from the western or
the Greek constellations and so we've
had a big research task finding out what
those constellations mean what the
backstories are and finding out how we
can turn those ideas into gameplay
elements
the importance of the sky is having this
Sky ground connection
having Layla use the constellations
abilities to solve puzzles and help with
Layla in defeating enemies the game
being 2.5 D you can actually walk into
the screen there's a lot there that
allow them to make the game very
cinematic
this is a brand new experience for me
building a team from the ground up we
found an amazing level designer in Nabil
and a coder in Idris and very recently
we found our technical artists in Zaki
and those three are the PowerHouse of
the studio and what I think is really
genuinely amazing that we found those
guys who are willing to work with us in
Doha I was very unsure about the amount
of talent for making video games in the
Middle East and I think we got super
lucky finding the team that we did for
me it all starts with a story and
pictures that triggers my imagination
it triggered immediately some music in
my mind beautiful Middle Eastern
Melodies to take them in the makams
to combine them with with harmonies
Western influences as well that it comes
together as a blend
in my mind designing son is a bit like
playing with Clay like trying to model
this clay with some manipulate it did
good
for example the hook shot is mostly made
by your tree branch
the footstep of the Scorpion walking
which is a mix of knives and souls the
voice of a Scorpio is my voice actually
has been overly processed when this
coconut attack when the Scorpion will
die attack that's my voice we're trying
really hard to make the game feel
magical particularly the part where the
player is trying to figure out the
puzzles
being in a country like the Philippines
were
my hometown had about zero pollution so
looking at the stars was one of my
hobbies which is why nightscape appealed
to me a lot
there's about 65 million people in the
Mina region who play games and there's a
very very sparse amount of content being
developed from within we want to push
that boundary and we want to create fun
and meaningful games with the Middle
East in mind utilizing its culture and
Rich traditions and history to really
Inspire ideas for games going forward
and ultimately build a bridge towards
understanding the Middle East but
it's the world too much or is it just me
everything I set upon unravels at my
feet
everything I've learned
wasted on a girl who doesn't know how to
be free
the games industry is always absolutely
convinced that we can only be this and
this only until someone comes along and
proves them wrong straight Gods is a
role-playing musical where you control
the song you play as Grace a College
Dropout who's not quite sure what to do
with her life a woman living in the
modern world who encounters the last of
the Greek muses
Calliope who dies in her arms passes on
her powers
and Grace discovers that the Greek gods
are alive and well and hidden in the
modern world
we think that stray God's kind of
appeals Beyond just fans of video games
it's a really unique story and a unique
experience there are so many elements
that go into this game to make it
special that you can attach to any one
of them and have an incredible
experience straight guys is what we call
a role-playing musical it's not really a
genre that's ever existed before you say
you didn't kill Calliope you have one
weak to
start singing This is a game with
branching musical numbers where the key
decisions in the story are made in
musical numbers that change depending on
your choices
the way that we tackle music is one that
people have never seen before boarding
multiple branching paths that should
link up to each other there's a lot of
considerations to factor in it's very
complicated but it feels very worth it
in the end
[Music]
we got to work with some of the best you
know the most talented voice actors in
the world the most talented people on
Broadway like what more could you ask
for really being able to work with some
Champions like Austin wintry David Gator
Troy Baker has been nuts at the end of
the day it came down to our composer
Austin he works some kind of dark magic
and you get it all back and you're like
don't know how you transformed that take
into this but it's absolutely amazing
[Music]
we have such incredibly complex
thoughtful characters in this game every
single character in the game has the
potential to be a favorite my favorite
character is Eros I really love
Aphrodite I think she is beautiful oh no
that's too hard of a question my
favorite character is think Orpheus my
king Orpheus he's my favorite it used to
be Hermes but Orpheus emo King love look
at me who do you think I am I'm saying
Medusa I am the number one Medusa fan in
the office I love Medusa and I love
Persephone and I adore Freddie
but my favorite I reckon my favorite
characters Freddy I'm really gonna go
against the Green here my favorite
character is Freddy everybody's gonna
say Freddy so I thought I'd say someone
else as well but my favorite
oh yeah I'll say Freddy but Medusa and
Calliope like it's really hard sorry
there is a level of belief in the studio
in the themes in this game and the
stories that it's trying to tell and the
people it's trying to involve and the
people that's trying to talk to that I
haven't seen on a lot of the games that
I've worked on in my career we've
assembled this Superstar group of people
it is a Voltron of game development
early on Liam made a conscious effort to
make sure that everyone that we hired
culturally fit but also had a conscious
effort to make sure that we weren't
hiring the same kind of people every
single person who came onto this project
brought something totally and uniquely
theirs it's one thing to be able to hire
to have diverse voices it's also another
thing to make sure that those voices are
heard it's just important for us that
everyone one feels safe enough to share
their opinion and two diverse enough
that many opinions are shared from all
sorts of walks of life at the end of the
day gaming is about joy and I really
like
um be reminded that making games can
also be about Joy
[Music]
very soon
the idols will be no more
lost in the morning
the expanse is an exceptional
intellectual property and that it's huge
and that the characters are the
Forefront of what they are focusing on
what is so compelling about it is that
it works in several different mediums
right I mean we begin with the books
and then I think what was so special
about the television show was that it
was almost like just another window of
looking in at the same story so what's
unique about the way that we tell
stories is that we give our players
agency over the character they're
playing which basically means their
choices shape the overall story so
they're actually living in the story as
opposed to just following along with it
when you're adapting a television
property into a video game property you
have to think about what the fan is
expecting and when they're coming into
this takes place years before the first
season we're getting to see the world
through Camino drummer's eyes she is a
belter somebody who's out in deep space
and has grown up there has never set
foot on a planet so her perspective is
really different
it's hard for me to look at these moons
without thinking about the other
research colonies exploiting all the
resources on them and giving nothing to
the belt
betray her
especially at the beginning of the video
game as
a little bit more vulnerable and open
and and to see the events that cause her
to harden just like series bossing
everyone around only this time no doors
to keep you on the leash yeah
oh
a really awesome character like drummer
deserves to have really interesting
situations to be put in that fans have
come to expect from the show and now
it's like they're getting to play an
episode of the expanse but in video game
form
we can do things like put zero g in the
game but we have to think about it from
what's a good interaction medium
and changing that from what you may have
seen in the show slightly to make sure
that it's something that you can rock
immediately and that feels good on the
sticks but that is also representative
of what you see in the show
those characters have really complex
issues that they're facing regularly and
in narrative games we want to give
players these gray areas to really think
is this the answer I wanted to choose or
do I want to choose this answer and that
they both have their upsides and their
downsides and so the expanse is perfect
for that drummer his suit is punctured
and losing pressure
release the Vault and Patch him now or
he could die
the way that that bolt has O2 fuel
armaments we can't afford to lose it
it was a really interesting challenge to
to come at the same character in a
completely different medium deck 9 is
video game Studio we are known for our
narrative our characters and our emotion
capture technology it's a completely
blank white room you've got some tape on
the floor maybe a few things made out of
wire to show where a door frame might be
or something like that but otherwise
it's Pure Imagination I assume you
didn't come here to talk about crystals
we have a new Target
what is it this time El Dorado the
Fountain of Youth let me guess
the Falcon horde of Venus
the unn ocean Nabi
cap believes there's something valuable
on board
something that we are really excited for
people to experience in the expansive
Telltale series is the emotional
performance that we're getting from our
actors that comes through with our
technology and from our animators that
really bring out the personality in
these characters I work for you but you
don't own me
believe me
I'm well aware
just want to make sure you're not having
second thoughts about our deal no come
on we're equal Partners we pay the crew
the costs and the overhead the rest is
50 50. you and me
I mean that's the joy and the beauty of
the job like this is that I get to play
we're hoping that you form these bonds
with these characters and that they are
something that you carry with you after
you're done playing the game and you're
thinking about it later that to me is
always a testament of of good
storytelling is am I thinking about it
long after I experienced the game itself
okay
[Music]
I am Julian Cordero and I'm the lead
developer and programmer and desperate
desperate is a game about soccer and
it's a slice of Life Adventure game set
in 2001 when Ecuador was really close to
qualifying to the World Cup for the
first time everybody was incredibly
excited about this moment and you see it
Through The Eyes of an eight-year-old
kid kicking a ball around with your
friends in the park
when I was growing up I played a lot of
soccer and Ecuador the culture of soccer
is very big and if you're a boy and
you're not playing soccer it's like it's
hard to make friends a lot like my best
friends I made were through playing
soccer but then when I moved to the US I
wasn't really watching or playing soccer
for a few years that sort of made me
like take a step back from it I sort of
like realized this and I was like oh
like this had such a big role in my life
I wanted to make this game to sort of
like figure out what it was that was
really interesting about soccer growing
up
when I started making the game the first
thing I focused on was this like
relationship with the ball and like
making the ball like this physical
object that you're kicking around more
than like creating like a soccer match I
knew that I wanted to just like your
relationship with the ball and like how
that sort of then relates to your
environment immediately was thinking
okay what did it look like and there was
this artist and musician Sebastian I
really liked his work my name is
and I am in charge of the art in the
spirit that includes 2D animation 3D
modeling and also the music This is
actually the first video game I have
ever worked in I knew the game was going
to be in 3D because I wanted the game to
be like feel very physical and this like
the physical connection with the ball we
wanted to find a graphic style that
could communicate emotions and we found
that the 2D hand drone animation was the
best way to do that
[Music]
we developed like the art style sort of
around like his previous work and his
style sort of feels very nostalgic to us
to have these like backgrounds with this
like very grainy aesthetic that was just
very important to have that Dynamic the
background being so noisy the character
is being so like hand-drawn and like so
clean
as soon as like I was like okay well
what's the setting for this game like
the only really idea I had was like
where I have played soccer in my life
which is in Quito that's where the game
sort of had to be set it became really
important for us like capture Quito in a
way that was like very true to us so
we're using a lot of pictures and the
buildings are all real buildings
some of the voices are from people that
we knew we wanted to have the same
feeling that you get when you listen to
people's conversation in the street
so that's why we went with the
improvisation for the dialogue it's all
improvised really we like approached a
lot of friends and family in Ecuador the
parents are played by my own parents so
there's an interesting Dynamic happening
there as you run around as a kid
the scene we said is it's 2001 the
record which is coming out of this big
economic crisis and there is this idea
we can qualify to the World Cup and
that's like really exciting and it's
been great because I think it's bringing
in a lot of this like sort of communal
understanding of the moment
so my parents aren't really big soccer
people but the excitement of qualifying
to the World Cup was so big that even
they were really excited about it
capturing this moment in time was
important because I think for my
generation the first time I qualified to
the World Cup it sort of meant like oh
Ecuador is a tiny little country but all
of a sudden we were like in the world
stage and we were like playing against
Italy and like we were like in the big
newspapers and that felt like a really
big thing pelota in Spanish means ball
and desperate sort of a saying that
people have is like
this is a mess so it's sort of like a
play on words like ball with a mess
we're growing up with this idea of Si SE
puede which is what the people chant to
the soccer team which means yeah we can
do it
like we can do it and we already did it
like that's not something my parents
were able to like grew up with people
like grasp onto it so much and I think
it like really
gave a lot of people so much hope and I
think for me like those that being like
one of my earliest memories it sort of
made me grow up thinking like oh yeah
like yes we can I hope that people
really enjoy just running around in
Quito I think we've built it in a way
that is based on a lot of our memories
like trying to recreate it directly
one-to-one it's it's more like a fuzzy
memory and I hope that feels very like
transportive for people and they can
experience what this moment in time in
Ecuador was and how I felt through that
time
thank you
[Music]